let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
by the way you know as we've been
talking about this hunter biden laptop
story that was buried by facebook and
twitter
and a big tech teaming up with big media
to cover this up
now personally as i've said i'm i'm
worried that the hunter biden stuff will
not
um have the effect that it should
it won't resonate with the voters i
don't know but i i have a
cynical view as i do most things with
this but big tech's attempts to censor
the story
i think that is something especially
that resonates with with voters because
voters are worried
about censorship and for good reason um
and you know i think there's a role for
the government to step in here but
you also have to balance that with
having them involved in the dangers of
getting
government involved in anything and so
there's a lot to balance and think about
that's why this week our own
ceo uh co-ceo jeremy boring launched a
new podcast titled enough
in his first episode released yesterday
jeremy takes on the leftist outlets
trying to get conservatives kicked off
of facebook this has been an effort
obviously that they've been engaged in
for a long time
listen now at the link in the
description and subscribe to jeremy's
podcast to get his other
his other rants about big government big
tech hollywood hypocrisy
anything else that comes to mind uh it's
a great podcast check it out and if you
like it
leave a review so it gets recommended uh
to more people all right we'll get to
our headlines here
um as you can see by the way boxes this
is my last this is our last day in this
in this house and so that's why
everything is empty and very sad
um more about that later though number
one a clip from joe biden
that he posted which is getting some
attention well
i'll just play it for you first watch
this america was an idea
an idea we hold these truths to be
self-evident
we've never lived up to it but we've
never walked away from it before
and i just think we have to be more
honest and let our kids know
as we raise them what actually did
happen
acknowledge our mistakes so we don't
repeat them
okay joe first of all no america is not
an idea it's a country it's a country
founded on
founded on certain ideas but it's not
itself an idea
uh this is not a pedantic
point here this is important the left
actually does want us to see america
as an idea and not a country because
that's how they
justify rampant unchecked immigration
that's that's that's how they do it
that's their line they say that
essentially as long as someone has
the same idea then they're already
american
they're already part of the country it's
just an idea
but no america is a legal entity it is a
country
and you know one of the ways i know that
is that because um i have to pay taxes
and so do you probably
you don't have to pay taxes to an idea
you pay taxes to a country
and i'm guessing that on tax day i can't
refuse to pay my taxes on the grounds
that
ideas don't cause money when the irs
comes knocking on my door
wondering why i haven't paid taxes i
can't like
rip a bong hit and say hey man
america's an idea bro okay
it's just like an idea chill out man
i something tells me that that that line
of reasoning that argument will not be
persuasive
to the irs agents but i don't know
number two from the daily wire says cnn
host chris cuomo was shamed by his
building manager and threatened with a
fine for disobeying regulations and
walking through the building
maskless fox news host tucker carlson
released a letter
that cuomo's building manager apparently
sent to the cnn personality on august
6th
outlining the complaints against him and
uh
i'll play this this is tucker reading
the letter listen
this show has obtained a letter from the
management of chris cuomo's new york
city apartment building
the letter in question is addressed
directly to chris cuomo the date on it
is august 6 2020. here's what it says
quote dear mr cuomo as i'm sure you know
because of the ongoing covid19 health
crisis
on april 15 2020 governor cuomo issued
executive order
202.17 which requires anyone over the
age of two to wear a face mask or cloth
that covers their
mouth and nose while in a public space
okay that's how it starts
it's a fair guess that chris cuomo
already knew that because
after all he's the mask guy and of
course his own brother
issued the order so with that in mind
listen to how the letter continues quote
you have been observed entering and
exiting the building
and riding the elevator without the
required face coverings
even though staff members have asked you
to comply with this requirement
you have refused to do so this is a
violation of the executive order
building policy and it places other
residents
and our staff at risk there are no
exceptions to this
rule and you are required to comply
the letter goes on to threaten chris
cuomo with a 500
fine if he continues to endanger his
neighbors and the city with his
masklessness
that's what the letter says yeah no
surprise there although i have to say i
do enjoy tucker carlson
casually destroying chris cuomo on his
show like twice a week now
it i i do enjoy it um someone has to do
it
and with the mask thing of course as
we've seen
time and time again pure hypocrisy not
just the mask thing but
lockdowns everything uh these people
that are pushing it they don't believe
it themselves
they don't think that that it applies to
them and it's really easy to support
something like a mask mandate a lockdown
when you
personally are exempt even if you're not
really exempt but if you feel like
you're exempt and you're gonna operate
that way then it's pretty easy to
advocate it for everybody else so more
of the same there number three
back to joe biden um finally giving his
i guess you could say his fullest answer
yet on the question of court packing
it's still not really an answer but it's
the most we've gotten from him here's
what he says
if elected what i will do is i'll put
together a national commission of
bipartisan commission of scholars
constitutional scholars democrats
republicans liberal conservatives
and i will uh ask them to over a 180
days come back to me with
recommendations as to how
to reform the court system because it's
getting out of whack
the way in which it's being handled and
it's not about court packing there's a
number of other
things that our constitutional scholars
have debated and i'd look to see
what recommendations that commission
might make so you're telling us you're
going to
study this issue about whether to pack
the court now
whether there's a number of alternatives
that are go well beyond packing
this is a live ball oh it is a live ball
no it is a live ball we're going to have
to do that
and you're going to find there's a lot
of conservative constitutional scholars
who are saying it as well
the last thing we need to do is turn the
supreme court into just a political
football whoever has the most votes gets
whatever they want
presidents come and go supreme court
justices stay for generations
it's getting out of whack he says it's
all out of whack
the courts are to be clear here um
when he says it's out of whack what he
means is that
republicans were able to confirm a few
justices
that's that's what out of whack is the
left's stranglehold on the court was
broken
and so that means the court is broken
that's what out of whack means
that's what they mean that's what the
left always means when they say
something is is out of whack broken
needs to be reformed desperate reform is
needed we need to change
it fundamentally fundamental change what
they mean is that
in this particular area things have not
gone
100 our way uh
and and so that's that's always what
they mean we need to reform it because
things have not worked out 100 how we
want them to
the whole thing is broken if this isn't
working exactly how i wanted to then it
must be broken
that's the only explanation i can come
up with number four
the speaking of it not going how they
want the senate judiciary committee
today voted
12-0 to advance amy coney barrett's
nomination sending it to
the senate vote uh i think they're a
vote on monday so to the full senate
the reason it was 12-0 is that all the
democrats boycotted the vote
poor guys they're very upset their
tummies hurt and they just weren't going
to show up
to vote i don't i don't know what so now
it's a unanimous
now it's a unanimous decision to move
her uh nomination forward
that's how they what are they even
trying to achieve here politically and
in terms of optics
you're upset you can't really say why
you're upset
well you don't like her because of her
what you perceive her ideology to be
but all this stuff that they tried about
how this is unprecedented this is
unconstitutional
of course that's ridiculous so they
couldn't come up with any good reason to
boycott but they did
politically though all you have done is
ensure that
now we can say she was unanimously
approved
by the senate judiciary committee good
job guys
number five finally the uh the website
538 has published what they call the
ultimate
definitive halloween candy power ranking
i don't know what method they used to
arrive at this
but it is a it is a fatally flawed
method i can tell you that
this is what their top 10 okay here's
here's their top ten
reese's peanut butter cup reese's
miniatures
twix kitkats snickers reese's pieces
milky way reese's stuffed with pieces
reese's stuffed with pieces
um peanut butter m ms and butterfinger
payday candy bars come don't don't come
don't make the list until
number 47. they put milk duds ahead of
paydays
and they've got nerds above mike and ike
speaking of speaking of out of whack
this list is out of whack it's absurd
it's offensive
reese's are way way way overrepresented
they're they they make up like half of
the top 10 if not more
which of course is to be expected for
the most overrated thing on earth
potentially
if i were to make a list my own list of
the most overrated things period
in all categories of existence it would
probably be
number one reese's number two dogs
number three the beetles
number four the beach number five star
wars those are the most overrated things
but reese's is definitely at the top of
that list
peanut butter itself is overrated
but reese's peanut butter isn't even
real peanut butter it's like some kind
of factory byproduct
with a vaguely peanuty flavor surrounded
by stale chocolate
snickers obviously is the best candy
just objectively and scientifically
speaking
paydays should be in the top five um
and if you've got a more mature adult
palette able to pick up on the
subtleties of flavor
uh then you're gonna you're gonna enjoy
payday mike and ike's are top five milky
way
probably rounds out the top five kitkats
are great
if you like the taste of cardboard
butterfingers are very good if you're
the sort of person who enjoys eating
congealed hardened vomit
um but it doesn't belong anywhere in the
top
100 or anywhere else on earth frankly so
this list is
an abomination as expected well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt
walsh show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content